I'm Jack Horner I first got involved
with the Jurassic Park movies when
Steven Spielberg called me up one day
and asked me if I'd like to work on a
movie if you're gonna have a battle
between indominus rex versus a t-rex
indominus has a much better chance of
grabbing hold of of t-rex and wrestling
him around a little bit but if t-rex
were able to get ahold of his neck like
that tyrannosaurus rex has a bite force
of about 12,000 pounds and if you look
at indominus mouth its teeth are really
not very big I mean they're sort of
gnarly look at me even though it's got
powerful arms and and and probably a
pretty good bite force it doesn't have
the bone crushing teeth that we see in
t-rex it would be a good fight but in
the end if t-rex got a good grip on it
and got his mouth around his neck I
think indominus would be in trouble it's
sort of 5050 here but indominus is a lot
bigger so indominus wins this fight
indominus rex against a raptor pack is a
whole different thing I don't think
there's any contest here
I think the Velociraptor is going to
easily win Velociraptor is going to come
not as a single individual but as four
or five individuals velociraptor can
jump on the back and use his slashing
claws to rip him open indominus is gonna
do is just sort oh we're all round
trying to get him off of him and I don't
think indominus stands a chance I think
he's dead
Velociraptor wins I have this one oh boy
and I take him to the roof this guy here
is Jojo and so as it comes in he's just
gonna open his mouth and the slavers
we're right in at the end of it